it's diabolical we know that he was the  number two donor to the Democratic party  and until about a month ago that was the  narrative and then we found out that the  chief operating officer that worked for  him was the number three donor to the  Republican party and and that guy gave  25 million to the Republicans in the  last few weeks so not he himself not  himself because he is fully uh  supportive of what the Democratic  beliefs said look I mean he wanted to be  viewed as remember he said he was going  to give a billion dollars in the next  election cycle yep yeah he might have  given a billion in the last election  cycle we don't know but he wanted to be  viewed as the as the great uh  Progressive Savior and finance here so  they gave they gave hundreds of millions  of dollars to celebrities they give  hundreds of millions of dollars to  academic institutions hundreds of  millions of dollars to politicians huge  amounts of money to journalists right  why wouldn't you